[Musik]
hallo sind sie auch so aufgeregt wie ich
sie kommen auch zum flug taxi das ist
die neueste technik die hatten wir
zuletzt in den 70er bei robbi tobbi und
das fliewatüüt sind sie es auch in
großen moment heute oder rufen noch
nicht unbedingt neue saison weil ich
dich an ze für schwachsinn halte ich für
für den kleinen mann geht der ganze kram
nun wahrscheinlich nur wieder für die
großkopferten ich würde gerade einen
sehr emotionalen moment muss ich sagen
so mich mich berührt das sehr bei der
erfindung des rades waren wir nicht
dabei aber heute ein flug taxi sind wir
da stimmt ja also ich finde es auch sehr
emotional
ein auto das fliegt ein taxi das in die
luft geht für mich persönlich ein wald
war
[Musik]
so jetzt muss es jeden moment so weit
sein jetzt wird das flug taxi abgeben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
für den cool aus jetzt muss er nur noch
fliegen wie jetzt das teil kann gar
nicht fliegen das ist ein dummy und
dafür die ganze show hier
wir lassen sie es nicht so sachlich
formulieren wie möglich was soll der
quatsch mir schon gedacht dass dies
nicht ganz schicken das ist die zukunft
steigen sie mal einen stolzen sechs
aller wenn sie erleben dass wir hier
zukunft machen in deutschland gut aber
es liegt ja nicht also ein flug taxi das
nicht fliegt wer für seine präsentation
nicht der flughafen ber der besucher
ausmachen hier in bayern die entwicklung
wir haben die tollen unternehmen die das
darstellen wie müsste ein pressetermin
aussehen damit er selbst ihn zu blöd ich
glaub das waren termingenau mit ihnen
ich bin so ein bisschen enttäuscht bin
extra früh aufgestanden kommen wir hin
und jetzt fließt auch einfach nicht ich
glaube es liegt an der heute-show wir
haben den flug heute abgesagt weil ich
mehr weil wir uns gedacht haben
da würden wir das so blöd darüber
berichtet komm lass es sein dass es am
boden ich wollte sie nur auf eine sache
hinweisen weil ich finde dass flug taxi
ich super mir ist nur ein detail
aufgefallen es fliegt nicht
[Gelächter]
taxis kann deutschland vertragen oder
anders gefragt wird es eine obergrenze
geben
ich glaube die frage nach der obergrenze
sollten wir beide dann mal diskutieren
wenn wir in unserem flug taxi sitzen
wenn man den schönen ausflug über bayern
hat
über die heimat werden wir das überleben
divisionsleiter mobilität was sonst dass
beide erleben kommen so jetzt hab ich
von scheuer die erlaubnis bekommen da
einzusteigen und wissen sie was das teil
hat nicht mal eine tür und gut
zurücklassen taxi
klickt hier für weitere heute schon
videos und clips moment
und klickt hier um den channel zu
abonnieren
[Musik]